just wave your hand above the glasses
and tell me what you feel nothing that's
the point okay
[Music]
how are you I'm Gary later thank you for
it yeah no worries
I actually although all the way here out
on the elevator I want to ask you a
question when I write something here you
got it cause we're shooting this looks
like by the way thank God I can't do
this because I be I be the worst one
five so it's 50 yes here Gary will say
fifteen no one else will tell you
because you put it in my head it's
[ __ ] the best I look but I believe in
this [ __ ] completely by the way he's
little bigger first of all experiencing
yes I always say to people it's not you
know supernatural powers it's based on
psychology or some LG lsq like a quick
question trying to go yes tell me the
name of your first kiss Kim okay okay so
by saying this to you
this causes the entire room to start
thinking see you special yeah okay yeah
Lindsey I'm just looking at you right
now
yeah enjoy the process just for
clarification you did not tell me the
name of a letter in the
don't see felicity
you felt something and I'm gonna write
something for you here oh it's so
impressive right mama where by the way
this is the best moment that ever happen
in my life okay no I'm being dead
serious this is the best moment of my
life
like you ever understand I love this so
much like like you understand there's no
there is no logical science explanation
for that it's that you've given our
Center I don't have this unfortunately
but I I have something I am I am
something in the way that I live my life
that is a cousin to this that makes me
understand its possibility exactly like
everything is gonna happen to me
it's III genuinely mean this I I know
that I don't again I don't have this but
the reason I absolutely don't understand
it but fundamentally understand why we
we are blown away by this is you just
have a extreme different version of
something that I know I'm living my life
as and so it makes sense I don't
understand it but but when I sell or
when I talk when I interact with a human
being and I just know everything that
they're thinking like I just know
everything that's going on yes I
understand
I'm by the way I get it I genuinely know
what's going on no but by the way by the
way it's so interesting and and and the
reason and the reason is seven years ago
I decided I would never get sick again
I'm not gonna get a second again I mean
I know it for a fact I don't wash my
hands I travel 180 days a year I bite my
fingernails I'm not I'm I am NOT I'm not
able to get sick mm-hmm I don't know
what to tell you I just think that we
grossly underestimate the brain in
normal society listen I get it so I
understand I really genuinely do it's
great to meet you tonight you'll like
this when I was saying my number five
came to me cuz it always that is my
favorite number but I was about to say
something and instead I said 215 I know
that I genuinely believed you I actually
could feel it happen I know you guys
know me a little bit like I get it I
literally get it I was trying to say
something else and I it's amazing I
actually just I'm going backwards right
now I was trying to say something else
and I was forced to say 15 I'm telling
you guys that's the truth
so I like harness this but I feel like
hot dun dun when are you back in New
York okay Tyler make it happen we'll do
a company-wide event because you work
with with brands yes people onstage
didn't blown away it came he's still a
wannabe yeah my show is I guess things
there's a crazy paradoxes it happens but
but then I started to invent something
but my inventions like infotainment
which means it's like a life commercial
I understand onstage I'll give you a
perfect for watch group for their watch
and I brought my thing onstage and he
stopped the watch is completed I'm
working and everybody with oh my god oh
my god but it was one girl that her
watch kept moving was acting like yeah
yeah of course
making fun because basically we remember
the extraordinary that's what
commercials are based on you will not
remember what you wore three weeks ago
on Monday but you will remember exactly
what happened and 9/11/2001 hundred
percent 100% second because it was an
experience so I create those ah moments
and I boom and I plug the message of the
company so in Germany I drove the car
blindfolded to say it accountant and you
BMW of the ice close so I create those
crazy crazy experiments it's fun to
invent you know ideas for technology
there's a company that I understand yeah
so what's the punch line right now like
help me reverse engineer okay what is
what what are you excited about in the
short and long term
short-term I'm excited to perform love
it if you live for it
it's your oxygen okay keep going I
understand that what's better than a
supposed to be totally get it all away
long-term it's how much take care about
the legacy yeah it should be yeah I
remember his father but that's it so you
don't remember who he was he's dead
right and there's like a hundred here
that's it it's not that's what this is
my friend right now right now my great
great great great great granddaughter is
watching this right now well so do you
know what I mean though [ __ ] cool I
I'm on a book and all positive thinking
because I really believe it's clever and
I you know I really love these concepts
[Music]
from your perspective I mean I have a
feeling of what you know and I don't
assume you know everything about how I
roll
do you do you feel as though what I feel
which is because I'm good at
communications that I myself have more
awareness in the marketplace then like I
should be the one that says it then I
deserve because I'm good at that and
that that the I know what you're doing
you're just putting people together yes
this device no one I've no one's gonna
billboards no one sitting there with me
magazine ads and things like that
television commercials people fast
forward so coming up with ways to take
products and services and your big thing
in which I've read your books you know
come up with a good product
yes service and you just think this is
an amazing product and he is who he is
and I know you're working with all these
companies do what you do
he's working with all these people that
needs to do it you do and put two people
in a in a room not say okay I just think
I'm a very good what do you how do you
categorize yourself master Mentalist yes
and who's the number one master
Mentalist in the world and does the
world believe that cool if I ask seven
point eight billion people who would be
number one I think you're right I think
you're right because you can I ask you a
real selfish question always do you want
them to see you I mean I mean it and I
need you know Prince
yeah yeah just passed away yeah I saw 18
years old you good I did a performance
for you and all those people's look like
0.1% of the this population knows about
me the people that can afford to have
you do private things at their home yes
go ahead sometimes you like your life
that's why I'm expensive that's why I'm
like I understand that's why I you know
managers and I understand you'd much
rather do seven events at a million
dollars each than fifty nine events to
do seven million dollars ooh I
understand would you would you because
if you really do love to perform you
wouldn't do to your business head would
do to no no I understand
like I would I would I would have thirty
charity events supporting
I understand it stuff like that but to
make a living I would do the minimum and
then focus on other things
177 for me ah I wrote it down right here
[Music]
I would do this 20 you know what's so
funny
like by the way the most interesting
part of this was I was literally able to
feel me being forced to say it yeah do a
lot of people understood that that's why
I feel like I've got something cause I I
mean it I'm the most sensitive no really
it's real sander okay
yes yes I don't know and I don't
actually actually you know that would be
a one place where I wouldn't be
competitive that would make me happy
because I think it's special no problem
okay you press a number to jail okay and
your first plus okay and you what you do
don't think about it just you situation
yep yep if this works that will be in
shop and you keep going I'll use it
91 yes already plus plus right I have
plus yes so one more like two digits
again two digits again and plus again
and you can do it
numbers keep going yes two digits boom
plus two digits plus and just okay go
faster yes
and now go to three digits did it plus
detector plus plus stop divide divide
equal score five to 109 great that's
your number yeah that's my number yeah
that's five to nine oh one ona five to
one own a [ __ ] love it
I believe in it the most and I and when
I tell you when I tell you that my
interest in magic when I was but I
respect into but like in my interest
level in this zero interest in believing
zero it's all practical I just know it's
real I know it's real I know it's real
no it's the craziest [ __ ] of all time
where you [ __ ] kidding like it the
craziest [ __ ] but - I understand so
listen I you know I could do this rest
of my life here's what I would say
because I think my intuition is you also
understand the way I understand I I
think I can really help I just need to
be able to reverse-engineer and I want
to help
it's where I'm comp most comfortable
over here you know three months ago
show me so I make you say yes no my show
is not the time for 20,000 people sure
so I had to invent yes of course um it
was so much fun and we didn't really get
it's important to let you barber was
singing and you had bottom part of the
show
yeah is leave the stage and say do we
think we do all this stuff and it's fun
but most of it to be doing scatter to
just creating all that students do this
and I think you you you could help us be
more alike with ideas and be more
organized or create something I think so
too if you know what it's better than
that it's a top line strategy
reverse-engineering the reality of what
you want person that's okay me too
because you know even in the show by the
way and Mentalist I cannot go on in a
show and start that's right that's right
I think of people think technology yeah
I have to go with a chalkboard
yep right stop now and show people that
it's affecting that it's really do you
have glasses
it's the grunting ah I'm not using mine
and I needed to come over here and do an
over-the-shoulder shot and you come here
and I want you to hear yeah you have to
be exactly just wait
what you feel nothing that's the point
okay
yeah I just you know it's the best no
way yes there's a piece of cake for him
for me after like you ask them to sweat
so listen I think so
so Tyler we need to obviously run get us
together let me like I want I want to
actually this is not something I want to
rush look I I get I I don't think any
like this all makes them this makes more
say something this makes more sense to
me than anybody you've ever met in your
life
now I what what I need is a little bit
more time to get you into a place for
what I do well in a comfortable place so
I can really help you great he just did
this you just did this thing I mean this
is enough five to 109
alright five to 109 it's like like none
of you know a hundred percent you know
and I think and this is kind of back to
like versions of the same game
I'm only most comfortable in providing
about like it's all gonna be like it's I
don't know any other move and the same
we can flip [ __ ] glasses like I'm not
interested in what I don't have that
Kier I don't know what's in it for me I
know I want to do it and then I'll like
do you understand me - alright Eva just
good I enjoyed that thank you so much
for having us and this and this is LA or
New York or any City a night that I need
I prefer New York okay but
it's fun it's fun I say quietly to Mike
that I prefer in New York to LA let's do
a cool picture
all right I need to I need to feel this
short term in the long term sure and
then I can really do some stuff okay
we'll figure it out in it arrange
something I will well you know what
that's all do
why don't we arrange something right
away for a company event and then and
then we'll spend the hour and a half
after it will talk I mean here's the
punchline what Lindsay why Lindsay's
here is we're building something that is
the future of all this which is what D
rocks doing it's a human production
company and and I don't need to sell it
I need to show it to you guys and then
we'll figure out what that means yeah
okay all right of course great to see
you
have a great day
[Music]